qu'est ce que dit gregory doucet qui a
été élu maire de lyon qu'est ce que dit
bruno bernard qui va diriger la
métropole
eh ben grégory doucet il dit l'écologie
n'est pas l'ennemi de l'économie
vous croyez que le secrétaire national
de élevés d'europe écologie les verts
eelv à dire ça au niveau national n'ont
jamais donc il ya une vraie capacité
avoir tenu compte de ce qu'on appelle un
microcosme politique culturelle quand
gérard collomb avait gagné lyon en 2001
il avait été capable de convaincre les
lyonnais qu'un maire socialiste s'était
pas dangereux et je crois créé gorille
doucet il a fait un petit peu ce qu'a
fait gérard collomb qui avait failli
gérard collomb en 2001 il a convaincu
les lyonnais qui élire un maire
écologiste s'était pas dangereux ça et
c'était vrai c'était pas gagné et à
bordeaux c'est tout à fait différent
pierre hurmic
c'est un avocat c'est quelqu'un qui a
été l'opposant historique alain juppé
depuis 30 ans 25 ans qui a même fait un
code de la rue alain juppé auquel alain
juppé a même proposé un moment d'être
son adjoint et qui a refusé
donc c'est aussi là cette capacité à
quelque part être à nos pauses en
jaillir à l'anglo saxonne savez comme
une sorte de shadow shadow cabinet tu là
où on fait on est l'opposant qui est
constructif mais qui est opiniâtre et
qui ne se laisse jamais avoir par la
possibilité de venir un adjoint s'est
pas toujours le cas
moi j'habite les hauts-de-seine
lorsqu'andré santini se s'associer à la
république en marche
il ya des gens qui ont été ses opposants
pendant des années qui brusquement vont
travailler qu'andré santini et ça c'est
quelque chose que les électeurs
n'apprécie pas par exemple les
associations d'entre deux tours entre la
république en marche et les républicains
ça n'a jamais fonctionné pendant sept
dans cette élection parce qu'il y avait
le sentiment que l'alliance de la carpe
et du lapin et est au fond une manière
de défendre des intérêts acquis il ya
quelque chose qui s'est passé dans cette
dynamique verte qui n'est pas seulement
due dégagisme au refuge faute d'avoir
une offre politique correct ça a été
aussi le fait de croire dans des
personnalités qui s'adaptait au
microcosme qui savait parler aux
électeurs localement et qui donnait le
sentiment d'avoir une forme d'éthique et
d'exemplarité
ensuite c'est mes revers ils vont avoir
une forte pression parce que être à la
tête d'un exécutif
franchement c'est nouveau pour les verts
français
[Musique]